turkey is stuck between a rock a hard
place and an even harder place first
Syria Turkey's president air Dewan wants
Syria's President Assad out which is why
erawan supports Syria's moderate rebels
but as the Syrian civil war has dragged
on more than a million refugees have
fled to Turkey second Isis we're pretty
much anti everyone the group poses a
major threat to Turkey's borders as it
fights with the Kurds the Kurds are an
ethnic minority spanning Syria Turkey
Iraq and Iran some want a separate state
but turkeys not having it so once it
starts to do join the fight against Isis
even if that could help Syria's
president not to mention the Kurdish
cause one more
download the aj+ mobile app and join the
conversation available in your app store
now